once a fool was so full part kids
welcome to the Woodstock food podcast
we're here every Wednesday live on
YouTube from 12:00 to 1:00 o'clock or
whenever the internet shuts down and
with real torian's right here was about
fool raver against right here the word
an air writer/producer no no I still got
published or picked up but out there
doing it and let's get started off I met
this guy like years ago Adam as some
backyard pupusas showing [ __ ]
Jose be show host of each time I saw him
up there Bellflower young bro look the
same age this guy like Benjamin Button
bro look 12 to a day he dies What's Up
mo Rodriguez in the house all the way
from Hunter park right now Norwalk
Norwalk middle everyone Norwalk huh hell
yeah that was Hebrew they should be at
room in Norwalk yeah there was the
Ramada yeah yeah
whose is it whose room was that
originally it's always rooting around
room okay I was thinking Esquivel no for
a while or he used to do some of the
nights and they know the boiling at it
right I wasn't down II know I was there
the guy wasn't them Rick martini martini
awful Firestone yeah did nor while
representing bro but a history buff yeah
I'm recording there man like and I would
like I wasn't even like some places you
will go like there will be at least one
decent shake that need to talk to you
know at least have a conversation or
feel good about just talking to anybody
I gotta say that played in Norwood the
bowling alley
there was no one you could do it there
was nobody that don't know you could do
it so hold a stroller have you like a 48
you're a woman there okay
you ain't drunk holding her bowling bag
for nobody was stealing it and then um I
gather I was running in the show he was
filming everybody bro
getting ready to do specials like I was
filming everybody he luminary show cuz
that camera was right there yeah and he
made into a special on a TV show
no yes attempt he was selling seed DVDs
of that show and Joe Diaz
a man was telling me oh you're lying
yeah I knew he was recorded I know he
was selling them though dude
what Norwalk famous Norwalk where dreams
happen and get taken away there you go
and then what do you got up the street
the center face means spot me that's my
hood little rooms in Norwalk huh
yeah and that other one that was good
for a while till I got shut down because
somebody got ran over it was a the
rosewood the remember well slowly at
Rosewood how can you forget that place
to open for food yeah well they closed
the one Norwalk now and now it's opened
like a few blocks down and I was caught
mr. Rosewood's there don't really
they're famous for their menudo the half
in half half menudo hypo solid because
it was a it was owned by an Asian dude
well yeah I know cuz uh he the only
reason I remember that room a lot is
because that's a room where she got
silenced by Johnny Quan in a truck and
load show the camper right yeah he was a
handyman he's gonna like hit hit one of
the bar he's a come on bro you can't be
doing this drummer bro see that's why I
let it burn don't you move ahead boy
you're the first time we Phillipe I
think I remember we met was in
Bellflower at a room that is like a
Mardi Gras room now I'm from Hollywood a
lot Bellflower Boulevard and I never met
Philippe we never talked and I remember
he came up to me after my sin he goes he
looks at me right away and he tells me
hey I know you played the guitar like I
was the first thing you said to me I
didn't know you played the guitar and I
was like it nice to meet you man mo
Rodriguez and then you look at me you go
what happened your tooth that tooth I
had yeah had a horrible focus right now
I had a rotting - really bad really
carries bro director out the back what
happened here tooth and then he looked
at me like really deep look and he goes
hey but your phone you're gonna get some
ass don't worry about it
I did thank you that was the best advice
I mean I was sold
so you know it's all conscious about the
tooth and he was the first one to
address and say and
you wanted to see the the rot he'll
still get asked don't worry about your
funny did you have a guitar at that time
I did have a guitar the last time I had
I did oh I like to like build confident
young coming oh he did know he I came
out of there confident I would like
first your your comic who like clueless
I will tell you the brochure do it this
time of that bathroom and whether
somebody's drunk why for sure to tell
you you're funny that we should never
hang out with you all day it won't be a
relationship just go her way
as usual beautiful something you just
like every word I just like I murdered
older comic just told me just stand
right there
like you just did something great what
do you mean like just say what you wanna
do okay but say you did already went to
the moon it's how I roll over the
television show bro just stand do it but
Jenelle already happened that's a good
idea though dog because you know put
your little chest up dog give him a
little wink so just do that dance bro it
oh you were funny thank you of course
you kept me there Bobby
somebody's gonna talk to you we're gonna
talk to you but if you borrow and go and
you're good-looking you stick a label if
your bomb and you're ugly you're running
tooth or ugly daughter that was the best
thing tell me when he told me hey man
you got a rotting tooth but you're funny
you're still gonna make it how are you
bro how about I like bleeding gums I
took a leak Rodrigo Rodriguez Bravo
when they had the Latino laugh at the
wall bro I wasn't in it I was like he
was not anymore
loitering he had got in the rug taken
out of here six months before the Latino
show because that that guy took his spot
I'm Paula Lee what's the name
Rene Rene Sandoval's yeah oh wait a
minute that wasn't I they told me we
want you to be part of row yes but we
need something funny so can you just do
like we're a mariachis suit so I lived
in Costa mess at that time so I had a
write from all the way to North in the
bus on a mariachi suit the whole time
and with the guitar with no strings it's
true story
it took me six hours to get to the club
once I got to the light you know what
we're not gonna use you and you know by
the time 12 o'clock comes out or 2 a.m.
the buses don't run so I had to wait
till like 6:00 in the morning at the bus
stop overnight so I got the bus start
running again and again came home of my
god she 0 sad is the worst time to do
that day though I was that night a
sketch they they wanted me to sing
serenade to someone whenever somebody
was bombing they want me to go up there
and play the guitar like a jack on like
yeah I was bringing my man you made me
wear money actually super six hours in
the bus going one way we're coming from
it's come from coast America far
sounds like a bus so you have to like
get like were the first right to I get
the four six to Anaheim down 30 minutes
did you get to Anaheim Rock
hit the 460 and of course is take you
all the way to downtown LA and there
from downtown LA I think it was like
four other buses and there was a delay
so there the foot suit of 460 man for
six that what was over Disneyland
yeah you know where we work together to
before with that fool do doing the homie
voices oh that's right I got Mundy dog
I'm gonna get to that other show they
took away from him that same week in the
six bus well he's the one that kind of I
took it away from you right well no no
what happened what happened what
happened on that way we came in right I
was a writer but they never you're right
the homies yeah I wasn't right or no
homies is the little homies are the
little dog that Eric collected like the
the graduating homie yeah and all that
but then they get the original guy named
David he wants to have a show on CTV on
Nelly TV yeah and then after a while I
mean I was all Berto I was I was a
writer and then you know they had me
just on one the real RIT right like just
riding all day with nobody telling you
to stop our pain or pain oh my god yeah
cuz they pays for that name pays for
that my voice and my name in the credit
- I was on I wasn't on camera persons do
that again - red carpets I did like all
these word carpets like Halloween red
carpet didn't get paid I think I didn't
go back cuz I didn't get paid and then
you know they try to lie to me they said
you come back this next week and we'll
pay you for last week what was shallow a
little baby face okay well you know
where I was working the same time I was
working part-time I quit a sound and the
marketing department I was the one that
would draw the little Indians and my toe
are the Saudis yeah you told me the
story of how they started yeah it turns
out it was it was by the way it's not
even owned by Latinos it's owned by
Jewish and they did it like finger hood
and they make you feel like you know was
they our job was to make it look like a
Latino company so half the day I was
working there and then the rest of their
take the bust all the way down to Bundy
man and got raped over there too like it
was just non-stop
told me same thing we'll pay you one day
they'd even spit on us taking a bus man
so when you were on well you have bull
riding how did the approach you like to
get the job first like we're gonna make
you a star that pretty much no I don't
even know how much it was only that it
was Richard Gere to me it was Rene Santo
ball and that other fool oh it was
Richard be at the Hollywood him problem
we should do that place and then the
reefer Friday's and then one day he was
like any other Friday right
he had the beginning like back in the
one you know just be these long lines
and long lines Jamie's office cheering
myself oh man
Richard did get paid and he didn't pay
anybody of course it did you got paid
here did get paid yeah so we were just
like oh you know we that was we love
that we love that place and then that's
when they would go and that's what we
were to get showcase and like TV came
over or Riviera came over there give me
as many as you can
I'm the studio and like give me a brown
one exactly it's shopping and I didn't
have a ride so I'm gonna wreck off
Fernando Flores April you won't be on
the show I'll remember this yeah he's
like you want the clean one or the dirty
one and he's like yeah but you know I so
I had to get him a spot on the show too
to get a ride let me tell you man you
know you know Super Mario Salazar yeah
yeah Corpus Christi Texas shout-out to
him you know funny guy but he's our
young comic and I was doing a show in
Corpus Christi and he lives in McAllen
so John Roman gave me a for guest spot
on my show ten minutes but I guess I
found out later that he couldn't get a
ride or parking corpus so he had he had
this other comedian I forgot his name
rebel man or rebel rebel man or whatever
your name is and that guy gave um charm
Mario right to the show but but what I
didn't know is that Mario had to give
him time so how's it hiding it so he
gave him five minutes so let's just
split the ten now it's tough out there
for your comic man it's tough but at
least back then we had to prove
ourselves like it wasn't like I'm gonna
put you up because he came back then you
put us up that was because number one
we've been doing it for a while doing
open mics we've been doing this and we
had to bring like a thousand people if
we wanted to do someone show now it's so
easier so Fred over for another floor
hero right to where you me read to letv
and then and then had a bomb a breakfast
burrito give you half if you have so we
bought one and shared it we show up
telling TV you know a drawer and they
were excited about another one great but
another
boom in there are the og migrant labor
dog not even migrant labour they get
paid this so I got it like I
entertainment pyramid scheme me and what
it was it was Rick on the top you know
everything he does and says would be
considered racist yeah you know he
wasn't ready
you told me oh you should look up to you
he's bullied at school so you believe
them he was he was even Pedro he was not
paid at all right Peter he wasn't paid
either because he was supposed to be
program director of the network a what
network they're doing that everybody
everybody was doing something free
hoping in order to get a position in
that place it doesn't what it does but
all it does is do a what do you call it
they do like the radio yeah and then and
then in the end we all were promised so
much money were promised and then not
only that they brought certain
celebrities I mean I remember the day we
went they fooled me his name yeah what's
the guy that died recently the director
John Singleton they brought him to LA TV
that was there that day we had to
interview him and I I mean I would throw
your rat into you know what to work and
then oh by the way can you go in the
booth and record eight different voices
for cholo horses know who the homies
right and the guys who ran the scripts
were like these intellectuals and I'm
like they had no idea what was going on
here oh they're already SNL for cholos
basically because they were doing these
sketches that went over a lot of
people's heads or like and the viewers
are like yeah it was good but we don't
get it okay like you know they didn't
know what the cholo whisperer
they did see a side cholo like they were
trying to sketch his that was do no one
really understood the references and
then we are job I mean I'm not gonna let
her talk I mean no now it is buts and at
one point though they had me spray paint
the background for the chortled more
needles bro yeah I was detailing that
one cholos how many hour you put in a
row dude I put in four hours cuz I did
that and I did three voices but then at
lunch they brought a subway
and then I just want this yeah I went to
Best Buy in amman no bro I just took off
dude a pen uh no and then cuz I knew it
just seemed weird like nothing what's
happening dude like and then I get play
air time I get three yeah I got three
voicemails one from Rene sandal ball one
from Rick and I had a buddy so when you
coming back
I wish I would have saved them and they
will use this one odelay
yeah they use your voicemails yeah so we
just want to know when you're coming
back buddy it's already been it's
already been two hours what's going on
here and they're talking to me like
bosses fool like could it mean yeah I
was already cashing checks well you know
what I paid the most in the whole thing
the guy who made the sets for the homies
and he even went over budget literature
set designer yeah didn't he and there
was a any here's the best part
you get television her editor their
editor was fired for the homies show so
I edited the last four episodes in my
home computer how about David what did
he get I don't know the creator of the
homies he because he was trying to do it
again later on to make any money right
the station's not giving him money
well the homies I shall cut the the
production the way that on TV it looked
good okay first of all I ended it in my
backyard it was it was just emotional my
god forever i edited the whole thing
on Final Cut Pro because they lost they
lost budget money cuz I know where the
money went to so they couldn't pay for
editing base well no they did a lot it
they didn't do it like they were
supposed to you crazy nations that they
did the chores just did this take a
picture back and forth back and forth
it's not not not real not real style and
it was all like that's real [ __ ] for now
Robert Solow who owns the troll
the hole means the rights to that these
days do you know I think letv still owns
it and I think they wanted they wanted
to meet them too I mean that could be a
great done now I'm surprised they don't
even sell them down now it could be
great if you know the right and even
David was to like contact people who
knew what they were doing but even but
he still gets screwed I mean look at the
swap meet all this stuff a lot of the
swamp yeah yeah that's it how do you
know who the first person that came up
to everybody and say let's do this for
me it was it was Richard via but he did
again he was working at Lee TV as a
writer for that show - he wrote most of
the episodes yeah it was not Hanna and
Rene sound of all that came up to me
that yeah it was Richard gone at that
point when they came up I don't I didn't
see him that day I don't see anything
but I mean he was working on it he was I
think he's a producer they came up to me
one time and then Pat buckos my manager
said I asked him for money shed for $200
a day at least sandy and then I never
got a no and yes but and then she never
called me back and told me they said no
so I'll just disappear
but then they had you come in like a
dish and I remember I dropped you here
for like two different auditions there
and they were like they chose Cisco
because it did it for free yeah yeah and
and then they had this taste of rap
there you go what'd he call it the city
rep that now she represents the
California Wendy Carrillo Wendy Korea
that's right she was my she was my
producer when we did the the honor
camera stuff they would send me out
dressed like a homie so nobody would
come up to me I was the fool and nobody
would come up to me brother
he made me just like what I had no idea
why nobody had an idea I get so low baby
do it no celebrity would come up to
Danny trouble was only came up to me for
the interview that was cool yeah it was
it was it was great man for me it was
fun I got to really be on set I got to
experience the business I got to
experience editing
after that you and Richard Channing
Sherm start doing that Spanish bicycle
then I want no no no they asked me to be
part of it because I was on that
new banda because that wasn't shy about
knowing banda back then yeah and I
remembered Ramiro Caro the one that
passed away Cesar Hernandez the singer
is very popular yeah yeah I remember
that I have a video that is on there
that was even said is gonna let's go to
Mexico bro I'm right now I'm good and
then that's when he got killed when he
went over there is that crazy yeah I
mean because you know these guys were
not American these guys I mean Mexican
ever Mexican American guys with the
Mexican mentality but you go to Mexico
you have the American mentality and you
gotta give us money for the show now
we're good you don't say no over there I
know he did a show in Mexico and TJ like
comedy show and I just told the guy who
put it together I said you know what you
keep all the money we don't even one
they might ok the openers and like
Felipe just wants to do you have a seat
that works if they come in to the show
you got to pay them and I'm like I don't
want any dealing with I put a show up if
I was a city guy man it makes it go just
drive around it's your big-ass life
that's what I'm saying they probably
they see a light on a block they have
the right you go inside into my money
huh no just [ __ ] they'll go over
there and [ __ ] going over or they
could do that here in America shut it
down
they have a tax legit tax this isn't
like that dudes may come in it's the
city that they don't always come into
the big gas density but yeah here for
this for the street vendors there's
people that come at you in a certain
area of course and if you're in their
block and some fruit you got a garden
work everybody pays taxes would you
start off doing stand-up comedy started
doing stand-up comedy at the ice house
and beautiful rental comedy class no I
was not for David's know the reason the
way I get it Bobby holiday know
Oliver Oliver now the way I got into
company I snoring theme great all who
else and then uncle Clyde a great Wilson
good one
the great Wilson but here the class - he
had a class to it yeah we started a
class yet a class the ha ha after his
class yeah no Roxy got a part on stage
oh man yeah I I went up all these
classes for you I didn't do the classes
no okay you were smart enough to get
jacked no I I went to theaters I was a
theater major so I never told you you
could hear - for free yeah well think
about it my dad illegal alien came to
this country didn't have any money he
hated his job and then his son gets a
job a clown for free he was pissed
is that my dad so I don't work like what
everybody knows the lower Curacao is and
Curacao is like the Mexican Latino Best
Buy
they'll give credit to anybody as long
as you want to leave your passport
they're like 25 to 30% interest yes the
ridiculous it's ridiculous and the only
other dog growing up as a kid I could
tell you right now that I'm the only
four major places that will give
immigrants credit and they were like
like pretty much borrowing furniture
from the mob yeah then it was la ooh la
la casa deardon's like Casa Phoenix
central like a central krystal krystal
emotional promotion and Astra and in the
Central Market
ya know people will give you could walk
a little console ah and meet Mexican
Santa Claus they're gonna call me booked
Woody Woodpecker on it cam a Mexican
coloring book Jeremy when we went to
Rena Center years ago gets me now they
were red red
well yeah we rented I think we're
running a couch or something and what we
were reading to own and I was looking
around and I think I was 14 and I was
like you know this is not a good idea
we're gonna end up paying more for this
guy one of my one of my worst first gigs
with me my little brothers we were
dressed up like Carlos Finlay Margot's
and to photo with people at centro
electric oh my god
so all day man how'd you guys get that
gig bro so hard to get to how I got it
wrong be selective dice to this acting
agency where you pay me 25 bucks a star
is born he was out of work so this is
Barbra Jean so this lady said that was
like Tori's so we were to that the
costume the costume palace or the
costume house right there and now on
Hollywood Boulevard right now where this
by the magic shop it's go there yeah
that place and they got all kinds of
costumes bro you want to be a [ __ ]
Mexican genie they got it you want to be
a Mexican Confederate soldier they got
it
so right there broke that Lady Justice
of like [ __ ] um she took you guys on
three yeah all over the [ __ ] that
we've rented or every Magos outfits that
lady paid to rent him and we went to
Grand Central potentially electric and
and while Washington and borough for
eight hours straight eight hours no
lunch okay with frankincense or yeah we
took photo with a bunch of kids about
your people you will not leave that word
to a secretaries are you kidding about
the colony about you guys they paid [ __ ]
yeah we got paid blow another TV bro we
are paid bro like budgeting put every
tire bro my brother my little brother
was do like in high school junior high
didn't get [ __ ] dawg
they gave me all the money brought on
again forty bucks each you were the
representative for all 300 you know
fifty dollars each for three days that's
not bad you know your ass bro they were
happy bro I'm gonna dress like freaking
the fool so my dad you're not getting
paid my dad was that was that gig human
I give a [ __ ] nothing
nothing clever we collected five big-ass
plastic bags Hefty's the big trash bags
you know the big help yeah we shoved
those three bags full of smashed
aluminum cans bro
that we collected now my dad and when we
got there bro they gave my dad like 38
bucks that food you bought or a dog told
I eat like he had carne asada
I had ham my brother had passed or and I
put to go by Oliver bro Wow and he gave
us one bag of chips and I'm Tapatio
sauce yeah yeah and one soda a salmon or
a 2-liter brother which was split after
that bro we said we started hiding our
cat somewhere else and taking our cans
without him dad from that I'm Robert De
Niro movie
boy's life [ __ ] I I was just thinking
about that because my mom kept my
brother is right about money and he
never got to spend it and then she spent
it because we needed stuff for the house
is she's using his paper route money he
was so angry and I was angry for him I
was like he worked for that I didn't see
the fairness in this I was like it's not
fair
I followed the little boys story when he
was three more over - yeah commercial
and then like bro but then we start
working with my dad
try putting sand in the [ __ ] aluminum
cans I am B B's and then like the people
that work there they know what a bad way
you had a scammer seek about a $50
did it work the first time at least yeah
but literally got too careless bro like
the bag threw the bag about rainy huh
after
while probably got greedy bro which is
it's a dumping dirt in the bag so what
else you do groans no you're no hustler
bro I'm doing a lot trying to so you're
the kid he's probably so hard no I want
my first job baby bunny
selling newspapers bro shoes first job
14 I lied about my age and I was a soda
fogging pizzas I was pizza salesman
Fabrice Aloka now from Paesanos pizzas
and subs and la palma I was I was over
Palma California was a hardcore
dishwasher work my way up to pepperoni
slicer and eventually pizza maker bro
[ __ ] luigi a pizza in La Palma
California yeah and then the hell you
were in a park La Palma is a little as
an island right is right is between
Hawaiian Gardens Buena Park with a more
yeah little the smaller smaller a little
required Michael a lot of retired
Lockheed people used to live there no we
did a lot it was fun man with court
thing about that was the first time I
learned about how to really like manage
money and lie to my parents because I
was also that guy that had to give my
mom and he's half a little cut when I
made that [ __ ] yeah if you give me the
musket my gosh the more you get the more
the more you give me the more God will
give you give me your shillings and I
won back I never got anything back out
Lana me your mom out there man you bout
taught you a bad way of doing thing
because thinking that way made you get
that job for free for free letv to this
day I'm waiting for my hope they will
pay me yeah I made me good prison alpha
B bro I would lie to my mom or your [ __ ]
yeah I did I give you like a look good
like like like if I had $200 20 bucks
but you know I fed the family because I
would mess up pizzas on purpose when you
mess up a pizza you can tell your home
please don't
what do you think a job like that's four
words I will be pleased to be you put
all that batter and all that philosophy
in a bag well I would give the wrong
water like they said one pepperoni oh I
put sausage in there Oh we'll take
another you deserve don't you go fired
in the end you know I think I knew I
mean he knew he was paying me fine five
bucks in an hour under the table I was
fourteen result was even allowed of me
and I was away I was working like nine
to ten hours god damn summer time was
warm I loved you huh and then it was fun
man and then eventually I just I went to
school and I started working on writing
and I got into the theater programs and
I became a thespian I worked for free
for the rest of my life
so what wouldn't you be at any Quinn's
cousin I'm a little sad that he quit my
he's he's my great-uncle my real name is
it was Oaxaca you know the history of
the last name Quinn it's bad it's a lie
bro the truth is what I heard about the
last day of my yeah the last name queen
and king toe I heard that the wound up
when the family were here you had a lot
of keen toes already you know like him
yeah but then I learned about mericans
her name is all Quinto yes he took
Quintana because they quinones and then
eventually quit you know King taquito so
we incur from Keane right yeah from the
King so soil yes ex v son was like was a
big thing for them it's all band's name
Quinto song it's very indigenous the
Anthony water became the original Latin
work in Tana or Quinn or Quinto no no
Quinn is it is Irish oh yeah the reality
he's from Chihuahua Mexico and during
those times a lot of the Irish came into
helping the railroads commercial work
defector from the Civil War and then
they also helped during the revolution
to use a lot of the guns in the
railroads for Korea and also that
Catholic Lee yeah so my grandfather is I
mean a lot of families Irish our
families Tarrant also so we have a lot
of Irish in us my Anthony Quinn's my
uncle his mom her name is Manuela Oaxaca
that's that's on my grandpa's side his
dad's name or was Quinn and he's
nourishment he came he lost contact of
his dad then she crossed over and that's
when he you know pretty much grew up in
East LA but really he was in Chihuahua
Mexico yeah because they tell the whole
story on the Lawrence of Arabia has a
little little history about to be clean
on their own yeah I uh so that's our
family anthony quinn as our is our he's
like a great uncle
and that's why alex his son that lives
in LA you know he didn't put you in the
will know i'm broken down to seven he's
not well but the first Latino the first
makes an American to win two Oscars or
would an Oscar and also it was well hit
but he there were two periods though in
Hollywood because there was a period in
Hollywood where it was generally a
shared you know joy of the cinematic
history and it included mexic yeah and
that's because the Mexico's golden era
yeah and it was that Mexico golden era
that was I mean it was just as accepted
it was almost like an its own NAFTA like
we went down there and got actors and
they made movies up here and I think it
all changed after World War Two the
whole commie thing and all that oh you
know Spanish is less and then spirit
especially here in the states if you
meet Latinos that are in their sixties
or seventies they used to they would
speak Spanish at home but if they would
speak Spanish at Californios they get
spanked Raquel Welch was a good example
right there Rosie in the originals yeah
no one who Rosie was Mexican yeah you
know and then Anthony Quinn did a lot of
movies that he played other races yes
and that's the best thing about him so
whenever people say oh they don't have
rules for us well I mean this guy who
went to Oscars playing what he's not
sore but uh you know I mean with the
bmobile in his for his orbit the Greek
and he still did it so I think it's a
lot of people just complain too much if
they're not that good at certain things
but there is also the race card in
Hollywood we I mean I experience that a
lot of times
networks pitching to networks they'll
read your stuff and I'll say we went to
a network I'm not gonna say the name
myself in my mentor when we pitched the
show they said it was great you know
that I measure mentors name about the
story I'll say right now with the story
years ago this is two years ago so we
went in there and then we pitched the
show and they loved the show they said
it was a great writer so it was an
amazing writer tell me all this [ __ ]
then you know we leave the meeting he's
like it was successful no because I sent
them a blank PDF of the show so they
just brought us in there just to meet
with us and they didn't never the script
you know I mean that just shows I mean
what do you do they don't do that with
anything I mean I mean I wouldn't say
that uh that's not normal but they did
it was me they're lazy with everybody I
should say I think so they're lazy in
general they're afraid to make any sort
of new risky decisions they follow the
decisions of their predecessors did you
go picture CBS no okay
we pictured a major Network though yeah
we played the NBC CBS ABC ATF it's a
rigmarole it's just like I mean the
thing is you can just always see who the
leader in the room is and who all the
other followers are and they're just
like oh yeah I was thinking the same
thing it's all yes-man yeah and they're
so afraid to make any decision on their
own nobody was losing their job and you
know we were just I was just listening
to this interview by Bob Iger the head
of Disney and he was talking about a
huge mistake he made it messed up he
messed up and then he was like
20-something and he stepped up and he
said you know what it was me oh I messed
everything up and they got they were so
excited that he stepped up it took
responsibility they didn't even care
they forgot about the problem shock it
shocked them because in that business in
Hollywood nobody takes responsibility
for that stuff they just they'll they'll
pass it on or I don't know who did it or
they're so so scared so it's pretty much
- it gets cracking where people start
talking in like it has to have that's
what I try to do a lot of my pilots try
to give more I try to give more momentum
and more hype than they
yeah you know have just to get everybody
excited just to get the network's
excited but when you do that you know
the roster comes in you guys seem like
it's a big deal ain't nothing you ain't
do nothing so I mean it's you try to use
certain methods but the same methods
will take you down from competitors but
that's what networks want they want
attention they want to see if they can
sell a product and want proof of concept
not on a little trailer but also in
numbers and in social media and
enthusiasm and in hashtags but we got to
have a front you know a united front
where we can now pick someone and go
with them I mean you can have a show you
get everyone to stand behind you it's
picked up not because it's a good or
good riddance because people are behind
it but it's also the whole game of
pitching an idea anyway though it
there's so few that make it through I'm
sure that's an art in itself right the
whole pitching are I mean we went
through pitching last year with pitching
again right now next week so a big pitch
week to the network's estudia already
said yea we have a studio behind us even
that studios sister partner network
won't didn't say yes they're like oh you
know we're on a different we're staying
away from family comedies okay well then
why did you know why did that studio
send us here to pitch even like what's
the point of the pitch you got a big no
yeah we go through all this stuff all
this stuff and then finally somebody
says yes and then you got to go through
another hurdle another hurdle I mean
it's not they're very close minded when
they're hearing things or they're
listening okay what if I what have I not
heard before that's really what they're
listening for you guys pitch a lot what
would you say to community first of all
you you can't come into it you can't
come into a meeting and say the reason I
let you know show out too like this cuz
there we heard that amazing yeah you
can't go in there saying that there is
no Latino shelter we're gonna have one
you gotta get forget about that and
don't even mention that are so Latino
you're sure we have a show that's funny
here the characters the characters it's
a 20 of these guys dimensions they're
all Latino those number names yeah and
then you go Endor this is a chaplain
show out there
it's about a single mom or a single
father about this is that what struggle
to enthrall everybody known a marionette
don't mention that
struggling going through everybody in
America cuz they don't want to hear
because they nationalizing your your
your sure to be a 30 ethnicity yeah
I mean I want to name your a star your
show broiler you're starting on [ __ ]
the same detergent that we used to wash
soap to wash clothes basically and bro I
don't you I don't care brothers one
Latino in them and you're pitching to
that Latino could be Aborigine broker
that person haven't open the mouth no
they are closed I remember I watch was
meeting and I saw assembly I see I saw
the same Latino person there yeah it was
the same white lady there and like and
when there was like a when there's
something that the woman did not
understand I mean that Latino person
could I opened their big mouth and
explain it yeah the person you're
working with I mean I don't have to be
the one to be explaining that to her
you're Latino or latina x2 you know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about
I shouldn't be the one explaining to
your boss what the hell I'm talking
about you should just be right there
like a Latino monkey saying hey you know
what it's like bingo they play it at
home I'm gonna do it all on the tree
like a bingo game like old-maid we all
played yes validation for us when we're
talking in there but no but she's
they're sitting there like she never
played yeah nobody wants to be a
trailblazer huh but the one who does
become a trailblazer then everybody
follows yes oh that's the girl that's
the woman from ABC who's every time I
say I go to a meeting she stands up oh I
love you Phillippe I'm a big fan and the
main lady gets up to him and that's
moving down I seen both of them moving
up because every time I go to a meeting
there are a higher place that's another
thing you run into those people as they
move up the ladder to if they stay
always they thank you they're happy to
see me I don't write no blog hate my
show
do I have it again I'm gonna give up
even if it there for 10 episodes yeah
this will be a long letter written by
Lisa in my words taking everybody for
the opportunity because at the end of
the day all you gonna do
thank you or you learn that from the
common clubs to other clubs you go you
staple continued business relations and
stewardess toes and then you move oh now
she flying the primary show that's on
the air it's just them it's just a
product bro if they get rid of it all
the other dealers get rid of chocolate
milk always remember he exists to sell
products television to you the great
stand-up career you have going because
that others are the transcend to
executives and your cable give a [ __ ]
how many times you sell at the Microsoft
right you're in control of your stand-up
you're not in control that yeah
the corner sponsors the people who buy
those products there and control your
show and you have to sit back and take
it if you want to keep your show in the
air that is that's just one of those the
writer when there isn't into the pitch
the night listening about giving you a
show the person is into it can I goes
can I go 20 episodes on this can I
manipulate it can I do a spinoff from
what yeah yeah brownish well they want
to look at the longevity they want a
little what's your story arc what's the
arc of this character and the season to
how much can we do like we were talking
about this character also man but don't
want nothing period periodic yeah it's
more expensive a period piece you can
have that something's gonna lead to the
next show because when it come on they
sell the show they're gonna be a the
person that buys it it's gonna be it's
gonna be it's gonna want to show this in
different parts what they can do a
prequel to it yet and they that's when
they can put big money to make it
periodically Fargo some people do but
it's hard not a sitcom it's harder to do
yeah so come have your free flowing you
can change anything can change a person
can die how we're gonna realize this
when we paste our show the first time
what do we get a deal me doesn't he
borrow he borrows in a studio backing
and they still said no without the
holding development me me money
and we got her [ __ ] our penalty fee
money it was a good year for penalties
[Laughter]
30 ways I know that I'm that year Angela
Johnson show didn't get picked up I
don't know how far it went
I know that fluffy show didn't get
picked up I know that my show in that
picked up I know that Paul Rodriguez and
Cheech Maureen and Portugal jr. show
didn't get picked up Jeana Briana and
also George know right well although it
was and you know who most up a lot of it
and I'll tell you a lot of companies
that don't say bad words that we're
putting they're putting money in what do
you call it in
Charley Rosado no and you to people they
thought that if they were to give people
who had millions of subscribers a
development deal there that's it when
they went to network they realize that
these YouTube stars weren't actors or
writers or the other fans will only
stand there for two seconds like her
like I love angry orange when I was 30
minutes yeah so that stopped a lot of a
lot of money was wasted for like three
seasons that and adding the the strike
of the writers during that time it
ruined so much people saying you know
what it's to develop a show and it
became the year of the era of I produced
my own show do you want to buy it it's
already shot here my twelve episodes
there's my 22 episodes how much you want
for it and I think we're barely getting
back into the studio's now producing
shows again like they used to except
this time they're on a different
platform they're Netflix Amazon Hulu
which is even better because you know
there's more avenues and there's more
there's more demographics on those
there's more yeah see you know not just
that what was the one back then what was
it called the the ratings were they
called the Nielsen ratings
yeah back and they wouldn't tell you
anything how many Mexican families had
Nielsen ratings box in your house when
that's on that ready
well now that the networks I think
they're dealing with shows like cable
networks like their operators take a
risk and give you a 20 episode
immediately sure we might give you six
or three like loss loss gave him three
reels loss was given three and they
didn't think them in your picture and I
got picked up like what are we doing out
here with no bill as far so let's get
lost or yeah let's get lost her lost in
space that's alright that's it did you
see that one on Netflix no so what's up
man what you got going on I have a
podcast going on the para Gordo activity
bucket that's paranormal right it's
paranormal but it's a fat guy so it's
para Gordo's yes si es la miss appearing
always talk about later the disappears
Berta burrito the sign of the Oh beast
no we have we have different we talked
about story chef right yeah they don't
have teen the DJ chef we're doing this
we're doing this amazing we're having
guests coming over stories and anybody
came in so like a good asked ghost story
oh yeah cuz I love that [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] Latino Julia Kukui I'm down oh
man we had one recently of a guy who
said he was possessed by a hundred
demons which of course here okay happy
to get you that bad back and then we
have one I mean I had I was wild I
remember one had a collective basket you
remember as it goes on yeah I used to do
guys do something and then that's what
got me into a man I saw some stuff that
I don't want ever want to see again
right Homans come alive at night tell me
you just Romani bro I got go through
deserve money so what you see well we
read that I had a medium you know the
guy that was you had a medium you've got
the first ever
waited for I was waiting for signature
fight that's a good not hippy was on
light love line he was a renowned
psychic I just have a regular you see
William Lord big just medium no so we
were we were doing the show and he's a
psychic he's all over the radio and he
says then we going to go some with you
we took him we went to the Alexandria
Hotel the one here on fifth and spring
that [ __ ] is haunted we went to the
wheat they gave us access for taxes we
did a whole investigation we didn't see
anything around 3:00 a.m. and all right
yeah there was around 3:00 a.m. they
asked us to go to the seventh floor we
don't see anything it was a room where
it were um one of the guys committed
suicide
Valentino come all the rooms and he
still haven't open the door lewberty no
yeah oh my god so they took away all
this all the cables we packed everything
up for leaving Ezra leaving elevator
opens up a little girl walks out about
nine years old when a pink dress smiles
at me and the medium psychic and she
goes and I hain't done why wouldn't
someone at the dawn around at 3:00 in
the morning
mm you know he's like well first of all
you just saw he saw an apparition that
wasn't really there and I think after I
saw that it was so real it was so on a
level where it was like a real person I
like it was transparent on that Bush
they say you know go start it was real
and I couldn't seem like a weak man you
couldn't see after that I couldn't
couldn't sleep because every time I
closed my eyes I saw the little girl so
after a month of research we found out
that in 1909 the Alexandria was built
and the architect his daughter fell on
the elevator shaft that's what we got
from that sort and then we actually have
an EVP electric voice phenomenon of
someone talking in there and we have a
video of black masks flying around in
the ballroom that you know the ballroom
together is black mask evil it's I mean
you can't you don't understand something
you know we tend to call it evil I don't
know Duras there's nothing to understand
so apparitions ghosts they're real
people real people they look like what
we saw but we have all these thoughts
made up
in a project four-bedroom apartment too
bad
one bath I thought I saw old lady pass
by right and then after that I found a
baseball right and then he was Joe
Jackson lesbian where were hardcore
lesbians and you can hear him grind the
way look this is the people I don't know
you know growing up we don't know we
don't know like any of anything other
but I'm the the male version of a
lesbian yeah but I don't know no other
lesbians that was hardcore yeah cuz this
chick is too well Levi Jack you brought
it'll be 100 degrees I said it a mother
bro that's hardcore
I share genes and Wallabies rule first
lesbian ever seen was a chola and then
her homegirl she had curly hair like
Dusty Rhodes bro no but I wanna be with
a hard race yeah yeah I deal with job
fools all day all day bro they're kind
of chains bro thank they'll be like sure
they'll be like like some pie so be like
catcalling them Amy mijo and then
they'll turn around bro and beat the
[ __ ] I remember that chick told me our
you know you know my aunt used to live
at the house she died there her grandma
died I did you play baseball
yeah you should have
Karen ran'tao ski on we had her on she's
probably the only person that I've ever
liked it like it's kind of like our idea
I can probably possibly she's really
good she's cool and she's funny too
and then Brian Scholl ro has a lot it
goes Brian solaro
yes great stories you told us a story
about that condo so in some city
cabinets were opening and then he
finally like made friends with it goes
every time I went to the bedroom
Janey's I don't remember where it was I
can't remember this story but or that
detail but he he said he every time I
would go into the bedroom to sleep that
all the cabinets would open and the
lights would turn on and then he came
out and then they would close and then
if so he made a deal with the ghost so
what if I sleep out here on the couch
and then he slept there and then the
cabinets all stayed closed but they
didn't want him in the bed we're gonna
hotel that's what I would've done
[ __ ] that I would got my drill [ __ ]
what's up fool upcoming show this week
baby imma be in Los Angeles finally Wow
October 4th the Microsoft Theatre the
next day I'll be a Yuma area Winterhaven
California catch on Casino Riverside
October 8th our Spanish show life Art
Center all the money goes to the life
Art Center you gotta come out here man
they got chips soda st. Paul Minnesota
October 11 all the way Center still mark
Cullen California October 5th Casa
Torres this place has tortillas it's
good stuff also San Antonio October 26th
Obon Center almost sold out there both
of those Riverside you can only buy
tickets at the door the day of the show
like what 7 o'clock doors open at 7:00
and then the Cazadores show those are
free shows but you got to come early
because they fill up fast and people
were there at 5 o'clock last time for an
8 o'clock show and hold it holding down
a barstool cuz it's a it's a bar show
it's smaller Chester
poutine October 16th in Boyle Heights at
the Paramount we have a show that is not
going to have anybody show up because
there wasn't be swatching Philebus bars
at the Microsoft family friends I have
family I have best friends that told me
hey man
I love you but I'm gonna go see Felipe
on Friday
like family to me Emilio Rivera calls me
he's a I know I was told you I wasn't
gonna show on friends ice house but he
hung go with Emilio yeah and he hasn't
got no no no not one nope whoa how'd you
beat the ice house on Friday at 10
o'clock and then I'm gonna be on the
27th of October at the Bray Improv also
doing the Perigord activity on stage um
the short of the one of the brain
probably get back to that so we'll day
after that the 27th of on Tyler's ticket
for sale you're their guest later
they're for sale that's a Saturday
Saturday October 27 map I don't go to
the activity anybody out there that has
a strange or yes a ghost encounter hit
up memores Vegas on Instagram and maybe
you maybe get a chance to say it on
stage pretty good chance
what's up poachy be George Lopez I met
George Lopez by crashing his studio and
in crashed his golf tournament I was I
went in the studio I I went as a
seat-filler and I told them for a
different show and then I stayed in the
restroom for about four hours
oh my and then I left you know the
audience are limited so I stayed in the
restroom for four hours once the closes
clear I came out I went on to the
soundstage I got to the soundstage I
come out with his cousin George
no I told up the page at the door that
George George my cousin to let me in and
then a PA stopped me and he said you're
nice cousin in Georgian are you yet no
and then I got just hide I was if tired
because I Hank I couldn't reach my back
so these zip ties would you tell him to
get out and see a tool of sin there I'm
sitting there so uncomfortable and then
after I was like going then he goes for
the sweep and then they let me do they
let me go on on the on the studio
audience into some time and then he told
me to go to the ice house and then years
later we'll see we'll see Bobby Oliver
so then a few years later I crashed his
globnar minute later which is difficult
copter my mother
Sculptra means I thought you were
looking through the winner for this up
of the card no it was one right in front
of morale brothers so I was waiting from
someone I got is Jackie
so I saw I mean the Rivera's pull up and
I went behind a meal in his car and he
was I was just talking all oh yeah I
know that photo you took photo that bit
you were abiding bro no I wasn't invited
I told me that was the second the third
one so wait you dressed up you were all
golfed out this guy walk I'll go find
one more golf shirts freakin pleats with
cleats like John Daly and you with high
khakis always I don't know what's ahead
and I had I liked it swapped me bag that
I bought oh god I would like two cloves
back coming up and her Joker serious
caddy so I'm at the gate and the guy and
the guys talking to me go secure stylist
Emilio and just so he knows that I'm
also supposed to be there I yell at me
Emilio what's up man
so that way Emilio looks at me insecure
Marina I know who got farther so once I
got it was my turn Eagle comedians
confusing me right now the worst times
out of me but you know looks like he's
trying sneakin millou
and behind me was the guy from the Big
Bang Theory or the Indian guy I don't
know his real name but I want to protect
so know him too so I will stop erosion
and him to like it what's up so now
everyone's the security like he's
supposed to being here
so when his might run touch security on
my emojis here to play up oh yeah big
day man [ __ ] him whatever he's like
well you know I don't know I'm like so I
research everybody who was involved - a
golfer I'm teaching my three we have our
latest used to be new
[ __ ] outta here ya know so I I wha the
guy glues him he goes you know what um
you're not on the list I'm not you know
I'm gonna call in the smoke what Bailey
here bro so I so would you want me call
in those small she's in charge of the
organization I could also call I named
all these names you know the people and
memorize a list of who was involved the
board members fool you got pacified
documents does I'm good in the smalls it
through NEMA and then sterling you know
what yeah just go ahead and just go
inside you dope here at the gold already
she's no favorite thing up for you so I
go in first first security checkpoint
then it's the second one is that the one
that's aligned to go into the actual you
know the golf course and on that one I
just you know how to get out of breath
I'll just put your rock around my car
um and I went towards the lady I pretend
I'll go to the bathroom really badly I
need a pee real bad I couldn't find the
restroom I got I can my car to put my my
clubs away she goes sweetie just go
straight here in there's a clubhouse so
I got into the clubhouse then I see
Amelia looking at me like you know has
like mother like don't talk to me talk
to me my two level talk to me like
people with my bell top dog right I mean
it was a school I'm like it's cool
George knows I'm here and George is
right behind me and I turn around and
George tells me he looks at me late
again
and then he goes listen have a good time
just stay out of the way so I was
there's a whole day a part of what
combined tonight is me and George having
drinks on this table and tell him ideas
on what we children here huh we start
talking what I'm doing am i some ideas
and then he's I hope you have ideas send
to me so we start talking and when we
came friends on Twitter and then
eventually we started working close and
now I you know I work on some great
projects with him and whatever James
almost they are I mean it got here with
the relationship based on false pretense
yes yeah
boy he saw me house after all that [ __ ]
you do over there for free but you got
something over here dog that was a
desperate move that was one of those
like last shot I have to you know do
something bro and because I you know I I
feel have talent I feel I know I do so I
just think the right opportunity and I
thought if I put myself in that
opportunity and they see it may be
something go ahead original clubhouse
yeah I'm good bring it bro Chloe we're
gonna need a golf let's bring it down
there's no way you could do that with a
homie huh no that's why I always I mean
people think that I just don't have a
clicker oh that I know I'm always about
myself because no cuz you're prepared to
sneak how the [ __ ] did you get into
tropicale yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] don't
know how are you I wasn't supposed to be
with you but this is you weigh me new
boy this for right because we were
standing over he goes Felipe goes Momo's
over there Momo's over there do I get in
trouble with [ __ ] like how could you
bring the whole uno past and I don't
have a red pen on me all time I always
tell me bro how am I supposed to be here
right now
how did you want but I know I know you
didn't pay to get it how did you get in
okay I got in through the back entrance
through a guy loved this guy by the
water no no by the stage where you guys
were at where your trainer was out
yeah oh yeah you keep it to the street I
walked
that's I snuck in there without a pass
because I wasn't ready now I want you
were sharing your wrist
why over the bridge there was no because
everybody was doing yeah there was no
burrs so I had a shy to walk away
there's school buses bringing bad it was
crazy I show up a night and then I see
those thieves not there's there they
were like their crew was there there's
clean huh couple of days so I walk into
the side and then I hit my boy up from
the others particles on my a man you
said you had a pass for me or I don't
know right now it's too busy I'm over
here like don't worry about how I figure
it out so I got in through somebody else
I knew that works for a tequila company
and I walked in with them I was like to
the VIP room from then I had somebody
walk me to the behind the stage that was
from the all those protocols they took
up the wristband they gave it to me and
I went in there and then after I give
art to making these hands to be there
will happen so then I go to the bag in
his Edison just stay here and don't go
anywhere and it was in the side of the
stage where you saw me just don't move
don't track attention to yourself don't
do anything don't make sure no one sees
you now I was I go fairly a bad when he
passes by and I start trying to Philippe
it and that we had a barrier right we
haven't even had a barrier I couldn't I
was made through a barrier I mentally
bury later on but they were even we were
behind the barrier he thought I was a
stage hand
well yeah but like we had we weren't
even supposed to be up on the side that
was their family only yeah Jamie Jamie
and then we had one of the guys like
help us go over there but they were
saying no to us and it was like but that
woman just told us to come with her and
she did you their daughter
I followed the chicken'll bemmon guy
[Applause]
playing the maracas dog following what's
how did you get there I got there Rhys
xam right when two bands before those
theaters also you that time they're
perfectly know you came here the café
tacuba
I missed along anyways yeah I miss you
and I such fellow Batman play yeah such
a kind of Batman and after that I knew
some of the guys I thought I did okay
besides this event which is small
compared to the
the that both of us look into yeah where
I've been the toughest play for you to
sneak in and the more rewarding oh man
that would be for me personally I'm a
big fan of Vicente Fernandez so I was a
long time ago I snuck into peek what
about a sports arena through the back
you know I'll do it how I know where
that's your tactic well you know where
they bring in the horses because they
have like a hottie give me a saddle
forget to the back I thought I broke
into the back part where they bring in
like all the guys dancing so after
they're done dancing the horses come out
in the rain they put the horse in the
trailer like if you were behind that you
can get through anything
yeah that night I'll run a cowboy hat
went through and I remember I didn't
have real boots
I had actually adidas on and I was Xena
boots I was sinking into that River oh I
was sinking into them because it was
first of all you know over a guy a
little heavier and that soil was so like
light I was sinking and then they had
bundle immanence it was coming off and I
was pretend to be one of their stage
guys so I was watching them and I just
kicked it right back behind one of the
rails or that guess the bull riders
going I just watched all cops right
there like if I was a boar any good
release bro but you're right you have to
be by yourself you carry all the homies
right because the whole no straggler who
just they get to this big old concert in
San Diego and Rodrigo just jumped the
fence it took off dummys and then Ivan
went when he jumped the fence the bottom
was loose and everyone under it like me
me and Vinny were scared so we went all
the way around it finally for the
opening there's always the best one that
got me work sneaking in was the golf
course for the Tony plana
classic computer the Tony plana Golf
Classic how'd you get of that it was in
the the one up in the City of Industry
so there's all these little Hills right
over there the Africa what it's called
the Pacific Palms up there and there's a
back
like a birthday yeah yeah so it's like
there's a lot of entrances from the back
so I got in through the back and I got
in there and I remember I got in for
using my LE TV press pass right so I
went in there and I thought oh and then
I start doing and I call my guys hey I
can get in
bring the camera crews so my homies show
up with the camera crew with all the
labral tears mics everything and I did I
did interviews I went around I don't
know how they gave why they gave me a
golf cart they gave me two of them I
went around interviewing everybody on
the celebrity tournament then in the end
Carlos Mencia was performing so I'm like
who's opening and then I think they had
an opener so I wrote my name on the
lineup that they had of the of the emcee
hat so they gave the line of two Tony
plana Tony plana you know what can
happen
so Tony plana reason we have what we're
gonna bring about the comedian before
Carlos comes he still golfing so give it
up for mister and he's trying to he know
who I was but he pretending he did very
funny guy I mean this guy happy to have
him here we're happy to have him here
you write yourself in as the closer so
they bring me up a stage and I'm working
I'm still wearing like sweats and golf
because I know what order golf
tournament there was no club out here I
knew about being athletic was wearing
sweats so I show up all right
I show up put your socks of it act like
they were like they gave me going liquor
Snickers I go up on stage and I see all
my heroes there were gyms almost on the
planet Andy Garcia other Latino legends
know my uncle yeah yes so I go up to
yeah and I go up and I just do I do like
15 minutes and I just one joke that I
did that got the attention of Cheech
Marin it was a yeah I was like I don't
usually I don't usually do with charity
events I got in trouble the last one I
said because I asked what the charity
was for and they're like it's battered
women and I was like ah sounds delicious
put me down for a dozen and it was a and
know and everybody was like nobody knew
what to say nobody know what to say in
fact some people were offended by that
joke and then Cheech is yours hilarious
and then and then she goes to Mencia you
could take your stick them on the road
just like that and then see what we're
doing this weekend like how you want to
go to Reno
let's go on the whirlwind the chaos I'm
here to our parlay their show would you
parlay that show it to sneaking into
Cheech & Chong's dressing room man I
wish man actually teach and I actually
started to develop a little bit of a
relationship with cheese cuz after you
know I always seen my Georges events
pretty much doesn't remember somebody
from the next from one event to the neck
yeah I'll take a person with it but then
you know Vanessa system with his
policies um she always like toss them in
the year man the whole thing kick us all
you're the homie show bro it was an
accident because an accident saw me in
the green room and I was you're a dirty
cheater too much I was in there I was in
the green room like I want to go put
something away from like a box oh I
don't know what I was a flyer some I put
it away and then I think B Rios people
thought I was trying to like who is this
moment wrap it up on my blizzy yeah so
they say who are you I'm on the show a
little while you're out on this show I'm
like no but I'm on the show the homies
in like well you're not performing
tonight so I don't think things
understood me and so they they took me
keep me out and then you know I have a
the bus they kick you out holding your
arm no they took they kicked me out with
two guys in yellow coats behind me I say
security what they say role they're like
you have just come with this big man
what's up here big man once I hear Obama
here with me
what's your bet you'll see that sad no
it's alright man what's your big man
with Tori so I walk they walk outside
and I'm out there I'm out there like
just sitting alright guys so I have no
fan on my shoe I can't take the bus cuz
my rides in there scam artists so Ricky
Harris opposed to in the morning
so it's 2:00 in the morning I'm out
there and I'm like I need a right oh man
the bus isn't right no more and I see a
Rick come out ever it goes oh you're
still here
I'm like yeah I'm here he's like yeah
right home
I suffer from night blindness so I can't
really give you a night a ride home yeah
yeah but he don't even like I just
pointed in Norwalk yeah you know here's
the Monica yeah something I gonna get
how am I gonna get home and he's like
it's a tough one man
that's a tough one and this and then he
just left me there and I think I just
got a ride then I wait till like 6:00 in
the morning to the bus round again so
there are him like this be kicked out of
be real make it away Suns on Sunset
Boulevard
you're there I am and then I watched
Mel's Diner and have my any money
Bronson I wasn't wrote and I was a rough
night anything after that she convinced
the waitress your cousin alright but I'm
stuck into some cool things and I've
been kicked out a lot of cool things can
you tell me how her knee G snuck into
his dressing room at the end of the
George Lopez taping what no bumble
wasn't around back to him though I know
I'm just saying like how what do you
think his methods were I he was he was
already kind of like begging at the
front door by the time we got there and
then we went around that's oh you were
there that night
you know at the theater and I know
that's creating all this and they know
that and I yeah you guys manager
couldn't even get you up he was even
like George didn't show up and he was
trying to host the show
yeah well George showed up later right
[Applause]
now see about respect people I break
into their [ __ ] but I respect people
there's a difference between [ __ ]
trying to [ __ ] be a [ __ ] Joel
Oprah would have showed up and saw
Bernie ji-ho oh he would have lost it
dude I would love to see that dog I
would love to see that he would have
finally gotten told what's up but when I
went backstage after the show Pat and I
walking backstage and then I walked into
the dressing room my soon-to-be husband
her client we couldn't get in there
Ernie Gees sitting on the couch in there
and it's just like like you know kill me
face I'm like get rid of this guy and
then George I think is about to come in
and say some I respect man see people
you know I respectfully good intentions
because Phillippi gave me my first paid
gig
whereas it was at the Alexander Hotel
that's right you had me yeah me open for
you pitch for you and then I thought we
were there for that Morris you know that
maggots all of those haunted yeah that's
yeah he was used the first comic to pay
me as it echoed in there huh that was
the first place they did the Academy
Awards that ballroom and his first
Academy Award ballroom was a the
Roosevelt Biltmore to the Biltmore oh
yeah and then you really like um you
were like um a question well the last
thing you snuck into the last Grammys
Grammys know the Latin Grammys that was
a little early on I snuck in that one as
a seat filler right
I got into the bravery si yeah yeah yeah
yeah so there's a bus that
picks him up over there by USC and there
was that the I forgot what they don't
know they didn't buy USC that theater
the shrine shrine so I to my friend look
man they're they're having seat fillers
gone they're all wearing tuxes and we
were touches on purpose because I knew
how it worked because I saw the year
before I was trying to do it so are you
recover ever I did so we went in there
and he was too afraid I'm myself again
come bring your friend I go in there I
get it I get into the bus and they send
me next to a lupillo Rivera right and
it'll still has a note there on the
other side and I'm sitting in you know
Alex in tech yeah I'm sitting Alex in
tech seat next to his wife so the rule
is once you're done during the
commercial break you can get up and then
that's when they come in and they tap
you for you to move the seat well he
came in he ran when he wasn't supposed
to during the commercial break and he
was somebody get up and I know the rules
I'm not supposed to get all your fired
because I think they were to pay me two
for this and so Alex intake against the
holy show with I thought yeah I'm like
no but I can't get up like my Spanish is
good and it's great but when another
Mexican speaks it with me are you
confused I got really bad I got really
been and he said you know I love this
music equals it's my seat you know this
is my wife and I'm like I understand
that good for you but that guy over
there now you're having an argument
again and I'm Aaron and so you see as my
sister says you could see us arguing
during the commercial where they pan and
they zoom in with the crane
me and Alex intake talking back and
forth so that guy comes is a unique it
up now so I get up and you see me like
it's lonely guys running down the aisle
they're like tell me to run I'm a fat
guy runs bro baby I said down and I bump
into the beauty rail bro coming down by
the in thing BAM because of the way his
hat falls and you see this all in the
background when they're coming in from
the horse show you're better off
bro yeah I got paid happy you uh he's
waiting any they pay you 50 bucks in a
poor local gift card donated of course
it was the Latin Grammys they they don't
have money money and it was a bad money
I'm late before that was a last concert
yeah and I snook I was looking to lie
good things but now think you know thank
God I'm being invited finally I was just
invited to those little saw Ramona
Yala's concert that was pretty cool man
take my mom and dad you know tonight
he's like yeah so my dad's like just act
natural and so they after the show the
the the board members of the fair
invited us to go to the VIP room and all
these Latinos were there talking to my
dad I saw him making lies up too cuz he
also they thought we weren't supposed to
be there that's where he's get it from
so no father
right so when I walk by you tell
everybody he has like 4,000 cows and
Chihuahua that he owns a for a long horn
yeah man beat the actress
hey man but let me tell you if it wasn't
him he snuck into this country
so that's right he just snuck away a job
next door
this country was already ours right but
that way bro before everybody else met
it it was fun man but yeah hitting it
Hickey with Momo where you fit in but no
matter what thank you cuz you really did
you need to help
oh I believe in you I believe that you
always tell me this is the one who stuck
around bro your hospitable oh he was
never a dick he was always cool oh I
know there was people who were dicks
with you dawg what about Momo is that he
was hanging around with people that
nobody liked it was been tough on you
huh yeah you didn't know you had a stink
on you know what I hung around with
everybody but I was everybody benefited
out because that bag tag retainment you
know I mean everybody has but everybody
has their own idea of someone and I
never like to be part of anybody's
clique
yeah I never follow out of time I want
experience with people if someone says I
do the dick well let me experience it
myself because I don't want to take
anybody because their day you know
casting directors I see how you know
they they judge you on you they don't
judge them out with somebody else says
all in individual yeah so I producer
I'll trade you and what somebody else
exactly the producer will but I you want
to have any clicks either because just
like I you know you
Filipa said you can't bring your home
with you sneak into things you also
can't be part of a clique to belong to
something greater than you which is
entertainment like it the other day you
know people Co see Philippe it because
they love Philippe you know and I want
one day be able to come see because they
love me not my clique start sneaking
into your show yes
well just look into a show for the I
don't know what group it was he made all
the way in and they passed him a cake I
want the system down show now cuz they
what they were happy enough yeah they
have their a cake and I only the guitar
player and the drummer came down to
Michelle branch's yeah okay so okay so
ten years ago she did a music video in
Long Beach at a bowling alley right next
to the roundabout in Long Beach there's
a little bowling alley right there but
they're in front of the first was my
friend we were there and we saw these
all these trucks all these you know grip
drugs and all these production trucks so
he wants to go beaches mostly what's
going on
and we ended up sneaking in to craft
service and we were eating or local
right they're just having a good time
again damn so we're having a good time
full circle with you right and we're
having a good time and then all of a
sudden they're located we need you guys
now and then they made me wear a trench
coat and they put like music like a like
a exact like a metronome like Bing Bing
Bing and it just had us like go back and
forth like this in a room in a in a room
in the bowling alley it was a Michelle
Branch video they put you in that room
those are all the people who snuck in
the skeleton came people were locals you
know where's that gift card I just
kicked out thank you well you gonna do
pop over to him you did a lot of balls
in your career [ __ ] yeah I saw I saw it
I mean that's kind of what you know also
inspired me like you know why you were
your own guy you didn't have somebody
else you put a uh you didn't have
anybody cookie cut you you know you know
follow what the other guys you were
around worried and you were with a lot
of guys that we were you know big-time
he didn't copy what they did and I saw
them myself on my own
he's his own person to this day everyone
says believe is Philippe and I think
that's where the comic wants he wants to
have his own identity and he won't serve
his own brand but he's too afraid and
too comfortable yeah
to make that leap Brazilians they get to
join Lopez um who we do my pool party
talk about some really that's a great
party man
that's a crazy part how hard would it be
to get to that point I invited um no and
then they were like part you know like
please have people that party were
questionable like I think the first one
Rob no no he was there and I was like
how dude in like 20 years
that's the horrible thing about having a
plus was I big dog like what's going on
you know pretty well that'll plus one
and then I think also you know as as the
night progresses no fool show up yeah I
came with fraser-smith buddy
plus three that were waiting out in the
hot in the driveway come over here now
dog goes he's drunk enough even though I
didn't go this here I I didn't go I
forgot a spot I went three years I've
gone for three years straight and I
didn't go last year but you see like
people just want to show up so bad and
they are bad but I mean and you know
there's more security now because I mean
through it is a guy who has great [ __ ]
his house I mean this guy has great
photos great memorabilia I mean how hard
would it be to walk girls without
anybody hitting it so hard
[ __ ] that I want the gun I don't Richard
Pryor's gun out of the car has he has
shut up the car I get that
well we posted it on [ __ ] you know no he
didn't but he has security like crazy
I'm in this guy that day of the he has
so much security he hires extra security
and then he has all these cameras I mean
come on you're like Hollywood and you're
like you know you know you're successful
a court shouldn't be trying to take care
of your stuff but you know the one day
that [ __ ] I'm or the one there
they are they used to worms they use
them before birth too late okay man
takes it out in camera once it gets dark
that place will be easy to penetrate
it's like the kid from catch that guy
could sneak into a party see but I like
to sneak in beam undetected dog I don't
be all like why going I sleep in a
network that's a truce everybody out so
I did a good night everyone
anyone ever spit at your badge or rip
The Bachelor II know I've had somebody
question me was Eddie Van Halen George
Lopez George Lopez comes to me goes hey
man
and you better hate ends wondering who
you are like what do you mean
I saw him getting kicked out by further
smoother Kellaway but he quite a strata
- [ __ ] stranglehold
where people go find us mommy mix on
Instagram on Momo Rodriguez on IG and
Momo Rodriguez on Twitter and also you
know come to any shore I'll put it up
there and well again have you sneaking
out will really appreciate oh my god one
more Audrey at people with um shows
coming up yeah well the Spanish show
that we have on next Tuesday in
Riverside the life Arts Center and also
uh October 16th at Paramount and Boyle
Heights we're doing a show with myself
Rizzo Jerry Garcia that the first night
of that comedy series what's up Oh
anybody want to invite Momo Rodriguez or
challenge him to sneak into anywhere hit
him up on instagram challenge him get in
where you fit in at home with podcast
come on I'm ghost funny entertaining